summer is around the corner and it's
time to make sure your home is
conserving water and following the
mandatory watering restrictions here's a
reminder from the southern nevada water
authority the sponsors of this segment
[Music]
i'm diana diaz with the southern nevada
water authority here to tell you about
the watering restrictions for summer the
mandatory summer watering restrictions
are in effect may through august which
means that you cannot water any day
between 11 am and 7 pm sunday watering
is prohibited year round it's
recommended that you water in the early
morning hours to avoid water loss to
evaporation or daytime winds
also slowly ramp up the number of days
that you water your grass in the summer
maintaining a three to four day weekly
watering schedule and adding additional
days as the summer heat increases will
help you reduce water use
save on your water bill and maintain a
healthy landscape to avoid over watering
water your grass no more than 12 minutes
total per watering day that's all your
grass needs run your sprinklers three
times a day four minutes each cycle with
about one hour space to part now if you
have a drip system you're watering your
plants you're watering trees you don't
need to operate your system every single
day in the summer set it to two to three
days a week all summer for one cycle of
30 to 90 minutes depending on the size
of your drip emitter
to learn more about how to water in the
summer some watering summer watering
tips you can visit
snwa.com waterways fines start at eighty
dollars and they can go up to twelve
hundred and eighty dollars for repeat
offenders
to avoid some really costly hefty fines
you know don't allow water to spray or
flow off your property follow the
mandatory seasonal watering restrictions
and fix and adjust broken sprinklers if
you see
water waste occurring in your
neighborhood in your community report it
to your local water provider water waste
is typically caused by inefficient or
improper landscape irrigation
to prevent waterways and to improve the
efficiency of your irrigation system you
can follow some simple steps and those
include checking your irrigation system
after you mow it for misaligned or
broken sprinklers
also
ensuring that your sprinkler heads are
the correct size or height for your
landscape also look for irrigation leaks
to learn more about how to prevent water
waste or to report waterways visit
snwa.com
and our thanks to the southern nevada
water authority for sponsoring this
segment you can get more water saving
tips by visiting
snwa.com or calling that phone number on
the screen 70258
save